so yeah
thanks for coming back to the second day
of the workshop
and uh to start us off uh you know we're
really lucky to have noah goliwicz who's
going to be telling us about his recent
work on you know the complexity of
marklev equilibria
in sarcastic games so i hope you all
enjoyed the talk
thanks dylan um i'm talking about uh
this paper with costa's descalakas um
and kai ching zhang
and the complexity of markov equilibrium
and stochastic gains
so nowadays a lot of applications of
reinforcement learning are multi-agent
in nature
this is the case for instance uh in
self-driving cars we have multiple cars
on a road each trying to reach their own
destination
it's the case in games like go and poker
where you have two or more players
competing against each other
um and some some game environment it's
also the case in multi-agent robotics
applications
where you have multiple robots who are
trying to either wrestle with with each
other or somehow compete with each other
in one way
now despite the fact that a lot of the
practical applications of rl
have multiple agents
the theory of rl
multi-agent rl lags a little bit behind
the theory of single agent rl and
there's some fundamental questions
that remain open
so in this talk i'm going to discuss
results regarding some basic questions
regarding the computation and learning
of equilibria in multiplayer tabular rl
environments in particular the setting
of stochastic games
um and i'll note that there is
concurrent work by yuji jin video muku
kumar and aaron sidford
which proves some similar results to
ours so video talked about these
yesterday and i'll mention uh later in
the talk uh a specific comparison with
our own results
okay so here's a very quick summary of
what we show
first of all we have a hardness result
for computing stationary course
correlated equilibrium in stochastic
games and then to complement that we
actually have not only an efficient uh
algorithm for computing these which is
folklore but actually a decentralized
algorithm for learning non-stationary
course correlated equilibria um in
stochastic games efficiently
so i'll begin um by discussing some
preliminaries
so we work in the model of stochastic
games um
and i'll briefly uh discuss
remind you what these are
so in particular we consider the
infinite horizon discounted m players to
cast the game
which is simply a tuple of a bunch of
components um here m is any positive
integer
so such a stochastic game g consists
first of all the finite set s of states
a finite set a
which is the product of m sets a1
through am
the set a is known as the joint action
set where each agent i from one to m has
action set ai
and we're gonna denote joint actions
namely those in the set a
using boldface
boldface a is simply the tuple
consisting of a1 through am
and the stochastic amg also has a
transition kernel which is denoted by p
so that p of s prime given s a for
states s and s prime and an action
profile a denotes the probability of
transitioning from s to s prime given
that agents at the state s play joint
action profile a
there's also a tuple r of reward
functions
um where each of the reward functions r1
to rm
takes this input is state and join
action profile
and outputs the reward that agent i
receives if players play action a it's
state s
finally gamma is a discount factor
between zero and one
and mu is a distribution over initial
states
what happens at each step is the system
is at some state s
each agent chooses an action ai given
the information
given the information about the state s
all these actions are passed to the
environment which
gives each agent some reward ri of essay
and then the environment also
transitions to a new state s prime drawn
from the distribution p
this is basically the same model that
many of the previous talks in this
workshop have discussed
um now in single agent reinforcement
learning there's pretty much a universal
goal which is to find an optimal policy
the setting in multi-agent rl is a
little bit different um
because it's not so clear what we mean
by optimal policy
we want to find some sort of equilibrium
as is typical multi-agent learning
but there's multiple different notions
of equilibrium each with their own
computational and statistical properties
and we have to be a little bit careful
in terms of finding out which source of
equilibrium we want to converge to
so i'll begin with one of the most basic
or most well-known types of equilibrium
known as nash equilibria
to explain what a nash equilibria is in
a stochastic game i'll need to introduce
a couple of definitions
so we say that a stationary policy or a
markov stationary policy pi is simply a
mapping from states to joint
distribution to distributions over joint
actions
so it tells
for each state
prescribes a distribution of actions the
agents will play at that state
and we say that the given the policy pi
the value function for player i v i pi
the mapping from states to reals which
is defined as follows
so given a state asset simply the
expected value of the infinite
discounted sum reward that agent i
receives
given that the system starts at state s
and then evolves according to the
transitions p where agents play
according to the policy pi
at each step
we're normalizing it by
one minus gamma in order for this thing
to have absolute value at most one
this is this is quite standard um
and we're also going to define v i pi of
mu for this initial distribution mu
we expect to be the expected value of v
i pi of s
if the initial state s is drawn from mu
so given this definition i can now
define an epsilon approximate stationary
nash equilibrium
as a stationary product policy pi which
has the property that for all agents i
the maximum amount that player i can
gain by deviating to some fixed policy
pi i prime
minus the value they would receive if
they just play according to the policy
pi
has to be at most epsilon
i haven't told you what product policies
are these are simply policies where the
distribution of actions at each state is
a product distribution
over the agent's action sets
so this is really exactly what you would
expect out of a nash equilibrium
um and in fact uh this is a little bit
unfortunate because
even if the game has a single state
uh it's a very simple stochastic game
um this notion of epsilon approximate
stationary nash equilibrium is exactly
the notion of epsilon approximate nash
equilibrium in a corresponding normal
form game
as some of the other speakers mentioned
you know we know that finding epsilon
nash in a normal form game is p-pad
complete
so that means that
certainly in general some markov games
with multiple states uh this thing is
also going to be p-pad complete
so if we want computationally efficient
algorithms we won't be able to find
algorithms that that compute epsilon
approximate stationary nash
so what do we do in light of this
well a very common idea uh say in the
study of normal form games is to instead
look for correlated equilibria or an
even uh weaker condition known as coarse
correlated equilibria
and such types of equilibria are known
to be computable in the setting of
normal form games because they can be
phrased as simply a linear program
what happens when we try to generalize
that to stochastic games
well there is
a definition here which we define an
epsilon approximate stationary coarse
correlated equilibrium or cce
is to cast the games to be a stationary
policy pie
such that for all players i
the same condition as i had in the
previous slide
uh holds
so once again the maximum amount of
player i could gain by deviating any
fixed policy is at most epsilon
so this is exactly the same as the
definition of nash on the previous slide
but no longer am i requiring the
the policy be a product policy
it's just any stationary policy so any
state the players can choose any joint
distribution over actions
now for technical reasons i'm going is
there a question
[Music]
how is it
[Music]
um so i'm also going to define a slight
strengthening of epsilon stationary cce
um for technical reasons so we define an
epsilon approximate perfect stationary
cce to be a stationary policy pi
so therefore all players i and all
initial states s
the maximum amount that player i can
gain by deviating when the system starts
at state s
has to be in most epsilon
so this is stronger than the former
notion because we're essentially
requiring that the former notion hold
for all initial state distributions mu
um and for those of you um who uh
were videos talk yesterday the notion
that that she talked about for hardness
for was the latter of these this notion
of perfect stationary cce
um so i'm gonna make a little bit of a
distinction between these two because
their complexity status is slightly
different
okay so we hope that maybe if we define
this relaxation nash equilibrium
because it's a convex thing in normal
form games we can compute it we might
hope that we could compute these in
stochastic games
unfortunately that's not the case um
what we have is this theorem that says
that for some constant epsilon bigger
than zero
the problem of computing epsilon perfect
stationary cce
and even two players to cast the games
with a constant discount factor
is p-pad hard
now for those of you who haven't seen
the complexity class p-pad
formally what it is is the complexity
class of all total search problems which
have a polynomial time reduction to
another search problem which is known as
the end of the line problem
the end of the line problem is believed
to be very difficult it's believed not
to have a polynomial time algorithm so
p-pad hardness means that such the
problem that we've shown here is also
rather unlikely to have a polynomial
time algorithm
um and so you know this should be taken
as evidence of intractability yeah does
the this constructor
to matter here or i'll mention that
later um it doesn't so we can we can get
things for all discount factors bigger
than that
now uh this shows hardness for a notion
of a slightly stronger notion of
equilibrium these perfect uh
these perfect stationary cce
um that's that's
a little stronger than the first notion
which is just stationary cce well what
can we say about stationary cce
we can actually get the same result
namely p-pad hardness for the you know
for constant epsilon two player games
and discount factor half
if you make an additional assumption
known as the pcp for p-pad conjunction
i won't tell you what this conjecture is
it doesn't doesn't really matter for the
purpose of this talk but you can think
of it as an analog of the pcp theorem
for np except for the complexity class
p-pad
now uh
well the pcp theorem is known it's been
known for several decades the pcp for
p-pad conjecture actually remains open
and uh
you shouldn't think of this as that
surprising because once again um because
the the uh
the the
the pcp basically gives you a way to um
show hardness of approximation yeah
yeah so want me to think of the pcp that
tells you that
um
approximating the
the maximum number of satisfiable
clauses in a given three-sided instance
is np-hard even to do it up to a
constant approximation factor
so
we know the problem of determining
whether a three-sided instance a
satisfiable satisfiability instance is
in fact satisfiable is empty hard it's
kind of the put a typical np-hard
problem but in fact even approximating
the maximum number of clauses that we
can satisfy
um is np-hard and that's the cut that's
the content of the pcp theorem
so it gives some hardness of
approximation for you know a very
standard
np-hard problem
and it shouldn't be that surprising that
something similar comes up here because
we're basically assuming hardness of
approximation for some
uh p-pad hard problem
and it turns out that if you assume that
then you can actually get this stronger
hardness approximation for stationary
cce
is that like a
common conjecture
yeah so there is some evidence that it
is true i mean it's not as well known as
a pcp theory um but uh
it was originally proposed to try to uh
show causing polynomial hardness of
computing the approximate notch
that problem has been solved by
different methods
um
the pcp feedback conjecture remains open
but
some of its implications have already
been established in the other methods so
it seems somewhat likely that it itself
might be true
but as far as i'm aware of it
so
if we don't want to assume the pcp for
ppac conjuncture because after all we
don't know if it's true
we can still get hardness um for
computing approximate stationary cce and
two players stochastic games as long as
we make this approximation uh somewhat
smaller so we show that um computing
approximate uh roughly one over n
stationary cce
is p-pad hard where n is the number of
states in the stochastic game
so one over n is much smaller than a
constant so that's why uh
it's possible to prove this without
assuming any sort of conjecture
okay now as someone asked a few minutes
ago
larger games with larger gamma are
always harder in the sense there's a
reduction that shows that if we can
solve games with larger gamma then we
can solve those with smaller gamma
so as an immediate consequence of these
results we get ppad hardness
for finding approximate cce for all
games the discount factor is at least a
half
and i'll also mention that it's known
that computing
approximate stationary cce lies in the
class p-pad
so
these problems i've mentioned are all
ppad
basically resolves the question of you
know what the complexity status is
uh of of these
problems let's now quickly overview the
proof of our hardness result
um the first step in it is to consider a
specific type of stochastic games
obviously if we can show hardness of
computing cc in subclasses to cast the
games that we get hardness in the set of
all class stochastic games
and this specific subset of the catholic
games is known as turn-based stochastic
games
which is stochastic games where any
state there's a single designated player
who acts at that state
now the reason this is a nice set of
games to consider
is that when only a single player acts
at a certain state
the space of product distributions over
a single player's action is just the
space of distributions over their
actions so the distinction between nash
equilibria and cce is is vacuous there's
no distinction between them
and so what we can do is
in the case of turn-based stochastic
games
result they mentioned the previous slide
about hardness of computing cce
is
implied
if we can show hardness of computing
stationary nash equilibria in turn-based
stochastic gains
because nash equilibrium cc are
equivalent in turn-based stochastic
the nice thing is that we actually can
show this so we even get hardness for
nash equilibria in turn-based stochastic
games
this is the result that uh
yuji nvidia and aaron uh proved
their result is slightly weaker because
they get hardness for s player games
where s is the number of states
um i'll mention in a couple of slides
how we can um kind of some of the
technical challenges that arise
improving this hardness for two player
games
[Music]
so
it's non-stationary i'm going to talk
about that in a few minutes
uh this stationary means that at each
state no matter what what step wrap
we're always playing the same uh
same action same distribution reactions
and when you actually relax and allow
you to play
different distributions or actions
depending on the step
then things become trackable
okay so um
the proof idea here is to reduce from a
problem which is known to be effect
hardened as the epsilon generalized
circuit problem
which is defined as follows
we're given a circuit which is simply a
collection of gates
as well as a bunch of wires between them
and each gate is of the following form
the first type of gate is a weighted
summation gate known by gs
which takes as input uh two real numbers
x and y and outputs
alpha x plus beta y where alpha and beta
are real numbers
there's a weighted summation of x and y
um here you think you should think of x
and y as being the outputs of other
gates in the circuit
we also have a comparison gate gc which
again takes as inputs x and y
outputs 1 if x is bigger than y 0 if x
is less than y it's allowed to output
anything if x is equal to y
and finally there's an assignment gate
ga which is parametrized by a single
number zeta
and has no inputs and outputs zeta
so the general second problem is we're
given a bunch of circuits of this form
wired up in some way
and the problem is to find an assignment
of real values to all wires of the
circuit all outputs of all gates
so that all of these constraints of all
these gates
are satisfied up to plus or minus
epsilon
so it's a search problem we want to find
some assignment um it turns out
an approximate assignment always exists
for all positive epsilon
in fact finding one uh is known to be
p-pad hard
this was shown initially for
exponentially small epsilon by das
klucky's goldberg and papadomitru and
over a sequence of works it was improved
to harness for constant epsilon
cumulating in this paper by avid
rubenstein
so
essentially what we do in our proof is
we show how to take
a given instance of the epsilon
generalized circuit problem
and show how to simulate each gate in
that generalized circuit using a
constant number of states and some turn
base to cast a gain
in this stochastic game will actually
have this special property that each
state has two actions so each set ai
is just zero one
and once we can do this we'll actually
be able to derive hardness
for computing nash equilibria
now i'll first mention
the proof of a slightly easier result in
our own
which is that we can get hardness for
computing nash equilibria and the number
of players is equal to the number of
states
these are like s state games
and this is this is exactly the result
that was shown in this concurrent work
with ours
um and the proof of this result uses
ideas from the initial paper by uh das
blockies bird and papadomitrol
so how do we do this well we have to
implement each gate in this circuit in a
stochastic game
so
i'm going to give one example here
suppose we take the summation gate and
suppose for simplicity the waiting
parameters are both half
we're going to create a little gadget in
a game in other words a collection of
states
with specified transitions between them
i won't tell you exactly what these are
but i will make one very simple
observation which is that because the
game that we're constructing is turnbase
and each action set is simply 0 1
a stationary policy
mapping from states distributions of
reactions is the same as the mapping
from states to zero one
because you can interpret pi of s as a
real number it's simply the probability
that the agent acting at s takes the
action one
then what we show here is that
for any constant epsilon there exists a
sufficiently small constant epsilon
prime
so that in any stochastic game which
contains this gadget for this circuit
it holds that
the value of the policy at one of these
states which i've denoted by sg
is the weighted sum in other words in
this case the mean of the value of the
policy at the two other states in the
gadget sf and sh
up to an additive epsilon
so this shows how we can implement a
weighted summation gate and we have
similar results for the other types of
gates in the circuit and that allows us
to show hardness when the number of
players
is equal to the number of states
so all players control a different state
now how do we get our
more
or slightly more challenging result
which is hardness for
two player games
well essentially what we're going to
have to do is we're going to have to
take all the states in the stochastic
game that we construct and partition
them into two sets give one player one
set and give the other player the other
set
the issue in doing this
is we're going to end up with some sort
of conflicts
so let me say a little bit more about
how this might arise
i've taken that same weighted summation
gate from the previous slide and i've
copied it up to here and instead of
showing you transitions i've shown you
instead the rewards
so in order to make this reduction that
i the simulation that i mentioned in the
previous slide work
we basically have to ensure that the
rewards to the different players in this
gate in this gadget
be certain values at certain states
and
well we have multiple gadgets in this
stochastic game corresponding to each
gate in the circuit
and i've shown you one additional gadget
uh in the upper left hand corner what
i've actually done is i've taken this
gadget i've essentially copied it over
where i've replaced the output node sg
with that output net sf
and i've copied over the reward
constraints
shown in red
now suppose that the way we partition
the states in this stochastic game is we
give all helper states
which are a certain subset of states
which i'll denote by w
uh to one player instead of other states
uh to some other player
turns out if we if we try to say you
know perform this partitioning of states
we're going to end up with a conflict
namely
at this state sf
for the gadget on the left we need the
reward of the w player to be one but for
this uh gadget on the right we need the
reward of the w player to be two
so
of course two does not equal one so
there's this there's some issue here and
we can't simultaneously satisfy the
reward constraints of both different
gadgets
so how do we deal with this issue well
we actually show that it's possible to
pre-process any generalized circuit
instance
in such a way that allows us to avoid
these conflicts
and this pre-processing uses some ideas
from this paper about rubenstein namely
uh his uh
united binary and binary to unary
construction so happy to
chat more about that offline but this is
roughly the way we get hardness for two
player games
okay so
now i'm gonna change directions a little
bit um so far the talk has been pretty
pessimistic
i've shown you things that we cannot do
well what can we do
what is computable in stochastic games
one way of getting around the p-pad
harness result i mentioned in the
previous slide
is to allow for computation of
non-stationary coarse correlated
equilibrium
now what is the non-stationary cce
first i have to tell you what a
non-stationary policy is it's simply a
collection of policies pi one pi two pi
three and so on where each pi h is
simply a mapping from states of
distribution distributions over actions
and then the policy pi says we play
action pi one and step one pi two at
step two pi three is step three and so
on so the choice of actions depends on
the time steps
so i've kind of
drawn that here
at each step we're choosing actions
according to a different distribution
now in epsilon non-stationary course
correlated equilibrium is simply a
non-stationary policy pi
so that for each player i the maximum
amount they can gain by deviating to any
fixed policy is at most epsilon
and so this is basically the same as
stationary cce
except that the policy no longer has to
be stationary
very simple it's very minor modification
of stationary cc
but interestingly um
as long as we relax the requirement of
stationarity
it becomes tractable
so that's how non-stationary cce can be
computed in polynomial time if we know
this to cast the game and the way to do
this is simply to use backwards
induction and the trunk gate after a
number of steps
uh depending on the discount factor such
that the rewards after that step
cease to matter
i'll say more about how to do this in
detail in a couple of slides
um but before doing so i'm going to
mention some of the prior work on
learning non-stationary cce
so this is kind of along the lines of
what a lot asked about
there has been a bunch of work on
learning uh non-stationary cce
when we don't know the markov game in
question we don't know as transitions or
rewards
um but most this work suffers from one
of two deficits so so one issue or you
know one possible thing that's been done
before
is
there's this paper by liu you bai and
jin which
shows that we can learn and mark of
non-stationary cc in stochastic games
but the time required is exponential in
the number of players
now
this is often called the curse of
multi-agents
and the reason that it occurs is because
the algorithm they use is model based
they essentially attempt to approximate
all the transitions of the model
because the transitions have a number of
parameters which depends the number of
joint action profiles which is
exponential in m
the algorithm can't be
there's no way it's going to be able to
run with polynomial samples of time
yesterday's talk show
yeah so that's the next bullet
so the second class of algorithms runs
in polynomial time the number of agents
but it has this issue which she
mentioned very briefly at the end which
is that it does not learn a markov
policy
let me say a little bit more about this
so there's several papers which do this
sort of thing they all use this
algorithm called the v learning
algorithm
and it avoids the curse of multi-agents
using regret minimization algorithms at
each state of the markov game
unfortunately the policies that outputs
are history dependent they're not
markovian
and in fact the
distribution um on actions at each step
of the output policy is a somewhat
complicated function of the policies
played by the bandit learners in the
course of the learning algorithm
throughout the you know throughout all
episodes of the learning process
the the like you know this people make
the non-stationary they're fun yeah so i
in
think
games
we only have gradients here you can
consider policy gradient methods and
maybe you can get something like that
uh that's an interesting question we've
actually been thinking about some
things along those lines uh but you know
you'd get a different notion of
equilibrium it'd be a little weaker
because it's somehow a little local in
nature because you're looking just at
the gradients
um but yeah we can turn off that offline
that's a great question
so um
the issue with relearning is that it
outputs it's a simple algorithm which is
nice
unfortunately these policies and outputs
are somewhat complicated
there's one additional benefit which is
that it's decentralized
so i'll take a quick detour to explain
what i mean by decentralized
so in a decentralized model what we
assume is that agents can only see their
states the state the systems at their
agents own actions and their own rewards
so i've kind of
drawn that schematically down at the
bottom
now in our algorithm we're going to
assume that agents actually have access
to a common random string r
this is used by the agents to correlate
their actions during the course of the
algorithm
i mentioned that this is not needed in v
learning during the course of the
algorithm it is needed in vlearning to
produce the output policy
so this assumption of common randomness
is one
way in which our decentralized setting
is a little bit stronger than that of
vlearning
but i think it's a relatively mild
assumption
and finally we assume that each agent
when choosing their own action perhaps
using the common randomness r
there's no communication allowed between
them they can't communicate with each
other or with any central coordinator
they have to do this on their own
so we're going to produce an algorithm
that works in this decentralized setting
as we learned
and i'll now be able to state what our
guarantee for algorithm is
um to do so i'll quickly remind you of
the learning model that we're working in
so we work in what's known as the
episodic pac-rl model
by episodic i mean simply that agent's
only access to the game is their ability
to repeatedly sample trajectories
namely a sequence of states and joint
action profiles
in the decentralized setting that i
discussed on the previous slide so in a
little more detail in the first episode
each player i
chooses a policy
and then sees the sequence of state
their own action their own reward next
state their own action their own reward
and so on
after doing this for a certain number of
steps
each player i choose another policy the
same thing happens and again and again
and again
and so that's that's how agents can
potentially learn information about the
game
um by pac rl i simply mean at the the
end of the interaction at the end of all
episodes we want the agents to output a
policy which is an epsilon cce with high
probability
now there's one thing i've overlooked a
little bit
which is that we're working at least up
until now in the infinite horizon
discounted setting
if we want this process to terminate you
know in polynomial time we can't let
these trajectories go on forever for an
infinite horizon we have to truncate
them in steps some step
so for our results in the infinite
horizon setting we're going to make the
assumption that trajectories are
truncated after a number of steps which
is log one over epsilon over one minus
gamma
which as i mentioned before is chosen in
a way so that rewards incurred after
this step
only contribute less than epsilon to
agent's value functions
now this is slightly
unnatural
and i'll mention that our result in fact
all the learning results in the previous
slide um hold in the
finite horizon setting
where we assume that there's only a
finite number of
uh a finite number of steps in the
interaction and
after some cap number of capital h of
steps uh the episode finishes
so we state our results for the final
horizon setting in the paper but in this
talk i'll i'll kind of
keep on discussing the infinite horizon
settings so as not to confuse you
okay so here's our theorem
what we show is that in this episodic
pack rl model of learning there is a
decentralized learning algorithm we call
it spock mar
which requires a number of samples
that's polynomial in all problem
parameters
it takes polynomial time
and it outputs an epsilon non-stationary
markov cc
with high probability
so like v-learning this is decentralized
although we do require common randomness
on likely learning
like we're learning these number of
samples is also polynomial although
our dependence on the polynomial factors
is a little bit worse than vlearning
but we get the additional thing that v
learning doesn't get
which is a markov policy it's a policy
that depends
only on the state
it's not history dependent
okay so finally i'll discuss how we
prove this theorem
um
to do so
i'm going to do a little bit of a
warm-up first
a few slides ago i mentioned this
folklore fact
that if we know a stochastic game we can
compute an epsilon non-stationary cce uh
in polynomial time
so how do we do this we're first going
to you know as i've done throughout the
rest of the talk truncate
the game
after a number of capital h of steps
which is which is this quantity right
here
which is safe because rewards after
those steps only contribute less than
epsilon to values
and so from this point on i can consider
this finite horizon setting where we
have
a number of states
which i've shown on the vertical axis
and steps in the horizon
uh shown on the horizontal axis
and to compute a cce
we're going to do so by backwards
induction so we're going to construct
value functions vih mapping from states
s to the real numbers
for each possible value of little h
an inductive matter and we're going to
do this backwards
so initially we're going to set vi
capital h plus one to be zero for all
states they're all agents i
this should be
interpreted as natural because after
this this this truncation step h
agents don't receive any rewards in the
truncated game
so their value function is zero with
that stuff
and the inductive step here
what are we gonna do
so suppose that we're given v i h plus
one for some little h
suppose um you know suppose for the
purpose for example that little h is two
so i have to know the fact that we know
v i three
by coloring all states at step three in
green
so green means we kind of know the value
function that state
and for each state s and agent i we're
going to construct a mapping fis from
join action profiles to reals
which
is a sort of q value function um it's
defined
right here
so so f i s of a
is simply the reward that agent i
receives
by playing joint action profile a and
state s
plus the expected value that they would
receive if the system transitions to a
new state
and we let their value be the value of
the new state which was computed uh
inductively so we assume that we already
know that value function
now the main point here is that
these functions fis from join action
profiles to reals
can be it as a normal form game specific
to this state s
the payoff matrices are simply f1s
through fms
so
because we know everything here we've
assumed that we know the game we can
compute an epsilon cce of this normal
form game that's going to be some
distribution of our joint action
profiles and we simply let that be pi h
of s
this pi hms is going to be part of the
non-stationary policy that we ultimately
output
and so we can then define v i h of s to
be the expected value of f i s
of a where the action a is drawn from
this policy
pi h of s
by doing this we've allowed ourselves to
compute
value functions at step h which in this
case is two
so essentially what we're doing here is
we're
we're computing these value functions
vih which
denote the value of the course
correlated equilibrium that we're in the
process of computing and we're doing it
backwards
now we can do this again for the first
step
and at the end we're going to output a
policy pi which is simply the
concatenation of these individual
policies pi h
and that's our non-stationary course
correlated equilibrium
uh how much time
say like
now there's one thing that i overlooked
here
which is that
we want to find an algorithm that
depends polynomially on the number of
ages
but these functions fis
uh it takes an exponential time to write
them down because they you know there's
an entry in fis for each joint action
profile a is exponentially many of those
so we can't really do this uh in a way
that's polynomial in the number of ages
there is an easy fix for this we
actually
no ways of computing epsilon cce
if we have oracle access to the game in
question in particular if you use a
bandit no regret learning algorithm
which requires that each step to only be
able to query a single joint action
profile
and it's a well-known fact that if we
run such a bandit no we get learning
algorithm for
one of our epson squared iterations
then we can take the empirical average
of the joint actions played by that band
in their regret learner and that uh
distribution will be in epsilon cce
so this gives us a way of computing this
epsilon cc you know there is
implementing this step
in actually polynomial time
uh
without without writing down
exponentially many different things
mainly using a query axis to this to
this game
it turns out that cory axis will be
implementable in the model of pack
learning that we that we're working in
okay so
besides being kind of important in terms
of avoiding exponential dependence on m
this idea of using bannon and everybody
learning algorithms is very useful more
generally when we don't know the
stochastic game
so as i mentioned before um this is
exactly what v-learning does
it replaces the idea of exact
computation of cce in these games fis
with a no regret learner
each state in for each for each agent
and v learning actually does something
additional which is that it doesn't
compute these value functions exactly at
each step
it only does incremental updates in the
values functions the v functions
and this these incremental updates
essentially lead to some sort of
complicated interdependence between the
v values uh computed at various stages
of the v learning algorithm
and this makes it very difficult to get
a markov policy
from v learning and it's not known how
to do that
so in order to get around this obstacle
in order to get a markov policy in the
case we don't know the stochastic game
we introduced some some techniques some
new techniques which is essentially a
combination of a multi-stage algorithm
as well as what's known as a policy
cover i'll explain that briefly
and these techniques combined allow us
to actually output a markov
non-stationary policy in polynomial time
in our parameters
now one downside of these techniques is
that they actually make it tricky to use
the upper confidence bound
type bonuses that v learning and many
other uh optimistic methods in rl use
so we actually have to use a more
primitive type of exploration bonuses
known as our max type bonuses which
dates back to brockman and tenonholtz
and these
our max type bonuses actually do
slightly worse sample complexity for
accuracy epsilon our sample complexity
scales as one over epsilon cubed whereas
v learning gets the tight one over
epsilon squared
so it's an interesting open question to
see if there's a way to say for instance
use ucb type bonuses to improve our
sample complexity down to one over
epsilon squared
so when we combine all these techniques
um we ultimately get an algorithm that
we call spotmar or stage-based policy
cover for multi-agent learning
with rmax
and this gives some rough intuition for
spock mark
i'll now describe it in a little bit
more detail
so i'm going to use the same schematic
that i had before
where on the horizontal axis we have
steps in the horizon on the vertical
axis we have states so here s is 4 h is
3.
initially in our algorithm all states
are unvisited
i'll note that by coloring all states
with the color red
there's no information known about
transitions or rewards
at each stage of our algorithm there's
going to be some subset of pairs uh hs
which have been visited and are known in
some sense
and formally what i mean is that there
exists some policy pi hs
the algorithm has computed up to this
point which is known to visit the state
hs with non-trivial probability
probably lower bounded by some by some
value
which is not that small
the set of these policies pi hs is known
as a policy cover
technically it's only a partial policy
cover we're in the process of
constructing it but throughout the
course then we're going to try to
construct a policy cover which visits
all pairs hs that we can possibly find
now we can't exactly do that though
because
in order to kind of find all possible
states that we need to visit that we
could visit we're going to have to
explore all possible joint action
profiles which as i mentioned previously
is not tractable
in time polynomial in the number of
agents
we have to kind of find a sort of
restricted policy cover that only
explores states that are reachable
under a sort of approximate cce type
policy
so how do we actually do this how do we
kind of build up this policy cover over
time in a way that's efficient
well and you've stated the algorithm for
all pairs hs in this set w of known
steps we're going to play the policy pi
hs which allows us to reach the pair hs
with decent probability
then once we reach that state we're
going to simply play a bandit no regret
learner at that state
each agent will you know play a single
step at the band and they're regret
learner
choose some action profile randomly then
transition to a new state s prime
and then we're going to update the
parameters of the abandoned very good
learner
by using
a value function we've already computed
at this step at the state h s prime for
the step h plus one
we're going to compute these value
functions v i h in a backwards induction
manner very similar to how i mentioned
on the previous slide when we knew the
markov game
now of course if we're completing this
vih in a backwards action matter we have
to
actually compute it at each step h
the way we do this is we're going to
average rewards from the bandit learner
and let that average rewards
be be the value vih of s
whenever hs is in the set of known
states
hs that do not belong to the set w of
known states we're simply going to set
vih of s to be the maximum possible
reward that any agent can incur
at step h for state s
and these are the rmax type bonuses it's
kind of a very
you know simple way of inducing
exploration
we're basically
telling each agent they really want to
get the states that we haven't visited
uh because the you know they receive
maximum reward there
the idea is that because we're kind of
inducing exploration with these rmax
type bonuses
it's going to happen relatively
frequently that the bandit learner at
some state hs which is known is going to
visit
a new state s prime with high
probability that was previously unknown
it turns out that we can use this
together with the fact that the state hs
is known
uh to compute a new policy say pi h plus
one s prime which visits the state s
prime with decent probability
then we can add that new policy to the
policy cover
and so then this new state s prime
becomes known
now the key point is that there's only a
finite number of states and steps so
this process has to terminate at some
point
and ultimately there's going to be some
step at which we don't learn any new uh
we don't learn any new state there's no
new thing added to the policy cover and
that step we can actually use the
policies of the bandit learner bennett
learning algorithms played at that stage
to output a non-stationary markov policy
we can actually show this thing will be
a cce
now at the end of the algorithm we may
not have explored all states there could
be some states like this red one here
which is not reachable at all that's
okay um we're gonna
we'll basically be able to explore all
states that we could explore by playing
something that looks like a stationary
cc a non-stationary cce
okay so um i don't have time to go
through the all the detailed pseudo code
but you can see our algorithm here um
center paper it's a little more
complicated than either
okay so i'll finally conclude
here's a quick table summary summarizing
our results
for stationary markov cce we have ppad
hardness both for computation and
therefore for learning
non-markov equilibria were already known
to be efficiently computable and
learnable
and we also felt this middle column
which is an intermediate notion of
equilibrium markov non-stationary
equilibrium
i explained how it's folklore that
they're computable in polynomial time
then i gave a
learning algorithm for them which is the
first such learning algorithm
that works in polynomial time
many open questions such as kind of
getting rid of this pcp for p-pad
conjecture
for hardness of computing
stationary cce
it'd be interesting at tighter sample
complexity for upper bound as well as a
more natural simpler algorithm
and finally extending our upper bounds
to settings and function approximation
is also an interesting question
thank you for listening
thanks a lot
let's see are there any uh questions to
start us off
[Music]
all right
which one uh you mentioned you were on
abandoned like a separate band without
going for each state
and it gives you cce for each state as
far as i understand is it easy to
combine to the
overall cc
analysis
uh it's not that hard uh much i'd say
it's easier for parallelism than we
learned
um basically like
it's similar to like um
when you basically get through some sort
of regret type decomposition
which shows that the amount you can gain
is kind of
we decompose
each state
that's like combining regrets to get
them like that
yeah
thanks
see uh any other questions oh yeah
i hope this question makes sense so
um for your decentralized algorithms uh
can you like when you're in a
centralized setting i can see how you
can simulate like that algorithm on a
turing machine
but for these decentralized algorithms
can you actually simulate all of the
players on one turing machine
like or is this the correct way of
thinking about it like how does this map
to
actual models of computation
if that makes sense i i would think of
submitting the players on different
terms machines like the point is they're
running different computers
and they're each doing their own thing
but then how do you how are you able to
compare a result in that world
to a result in a centralized world
because you're in a completely different
model of computation
so it's a fair point like you do need
like it's kind of paralyzed in the sense
that you have m different computers
which are each fundamental algorithm so
if you want it like what you can do is
you can take any decentralized algorithm
just kind of
uh interleave the steps
and you'll and in the central setting
you'll take at least at most m times
the
computation of any individual piece
so
the sort of kind of uh time complexity
we get is at most m times more in the
centralized setting and then but then
how is that different than running this
on a non-deterministic turing machine
because you're still having all of these
machines that are not communicating with
each other
and everything is running at the same
time
um
there's no need to introduce
non-optimism here because
i'm not saying that you need to
introduce it i'm saying that like when
you consider this model competition
where everyone has their own turing
machine and they're running this yeah
you essentially are running a turning
mach a non-deterministic turing machine
now uh
not really it's more of a parallel thing
like uh
usually non-determinism comes in when
you want to guess the polynomial number
of bits
um that's not necessary here like here
we're just kind of
running a bunch of deterministic
algorithms in parallel okay and then
could you then convert though this
model of competition where you have all
of these turing machines into a most
centralized version
where you're running everything on one
turning machine yes yes yes so okay you
basically just kind of for each step you
know after each directory you just run
each of the agent's algorithms
so okay there's a sequence and then you
get you can basically simulate the
decentralized computation essentially
that's immediate oh the fact that you
run them in sequence doesn't mess things
up
okay that's cool awesome thanks
uh
can you oh okay let me go over here
um just a very good question uh can you
say anything about the practical
performance of this like have you
benchmarked this on any domains or
compared to vlearning for instance uh
it's a great question we haven't um i
expect relearning would probably work
better it's simpler and usually usually
like simpler algorithm practice
um
but it's a little incomparable because
you know we're producing a different
guarantee we get a markov policy so
um
i'm not sure like it's it's it's like
direct comparisons if you're learning
isn't completely fair because they're
the goals of the odd ones are different
okay thank you
uh no can you maybe say a little bit
about like challenges of extending to
like function approximation uh yeah so i
think
um
it's a great question i haven't thought
about it that much um but i think it
might be even a little easier to extend
this to say linear function
approximation and e-learning
um because like
uh
this rmax idea seems
quite possible to extend yeah for sure
basically you're just trying to learn
like instead of learning each state
you're trying to learn each dimension in
each step
and it seems like that should be doable
yeah certainly there's certainly like
policy cover type algorithms for linear
function approximation in like the
single agent setting you know which do
you use
like you know this more crude notion of
bonuses what are they talking about yeah
yeah so like i mean i assume you're
using some sort of like uh optimal
design type things i also i'm thinking
like even more crude like if you've ever
seen this like fond bay paper
okay uh yeah oh you're right they they
do yeah we can talk about it offline
yeah that's a good point yeah
that's work
cool
are there any more questions
all right why don't we take a quick 10
minute break and then we'll be back at
uh 10 15 for a lot stock
and let's give it a one more round of
applause